[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand on voit les événements qui ont
lieu cet été à on voit qu'on a déjà des
conséquences très important de
changements climatiques également elle
aurait fallu agir beaucoup plus tôt et
on aurait pu éviter ce genre d'événement
disons si on avait été plus rapide agile
on a eu des températures de près de 50
degrés qui ont été atteintes au canada
et donc il faut s'imaginer quand même le
canada ces images en a c'est au nord et
d'avoir des températures pareilles qui
ont été atteintes avec 17 forêt après
qu'on ait des conséquences dramatiques
c'est certainement ce genre d'événement
on s'attend à voir de plus en plus
souvent et pas seulement d'un supérieur
au canada mais dans d'autres régions et
comme on voit les régions du nord ne
sont pas épargnés
[Musique]
on a étudié cinq différents scénarios
dans le rapport du giec qui sont basés
sur la littérature le scénario avec le
moins d'émissions de co2 arrive à peu
près un point 6 degrés au milieu du
siècle et redescend à peu près à 1.5 de
dire à la fin du siècle le pire scénario
arrive bien au dessus de 4 degrés à la
fin du siècle et pour certains modèles
mais bien au dessus de 5 degrés est pour
l'instant on est plutôt sur une
trajectoire qui nous amènerait à peu
près 3 degrés de réchauffement global à
la fin du siècle
en
[Musique]
pour la région des andes europe centrale
et de l'ouest 1 on voit en fait de
nombreux changements c'est une région
qui est le plus touché par les
changements climatiques parce que
d'abord on a des augmentations des
canicules comme c'est le cas partout
mais on a aussi une augmentation des
précipitations intenses qu'on voit dans
le passé et qui aussi projeter
d'augmenter les ans avec plus de
réchauffement et on voit aussi un plus
de risques de sécheresse donc au tour
des deux degrés on a un niveau de
confiance moyenne qui nous dit que
n'aura plus en fait de sécheresse qui
vont avoir des conséquences pour avec
les cultures et aussi les écosystèmes et
par ailleurs on voit dans les
observations déjà une tendance à
l'assèchement donc on voit déjà ces
trois éléments qui sont importants par
ailleurs on a aussi une augmentation
de des tempêtes et dans les régions de
montagne des impacts traditionnel thé
que la fonte du pergélisol
aussi la fonte des glaciers la fonte de
la neige
[Musique]
oh
vous faites une grande partie des
émissions de co2 que nous avons dans
l'atmosphère sont capturées de manière
naturelle par les océans et les
continents donc en fait seulement il
faut une fraction du co2 émis qui reste
dans l'atmosphère malheureusement c'est
plus de carbone devient moins efficace
lorsqu'on a une augmentation du
réchauffement global
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a vraiment eu le temps d'attendre
c'est maintenant je pensais la dernière
possibilité pour
changer de trajectoire si on regarde
vraiment l'évolution des concentrations
de co2 il ya de quoi être pessimiste
parce qu'on voit que dans les faits rien
ne s'est amélioré alors j'attends de
voir ce qui se passera à la coop si des
décisions sont prises qui sont suivies
d'actions oui je pense que il a raison à
être optimiste à ce moment là mais
j'attends de voir parce que pour
l'instant j'ai parlé des actions
concrètes